ce traditionnel chez nous c'est maloya
le séga élevé les c'est différent parce
que les passants un petit peu complexe
d'activités nos émotions des fois été
mise à rude épreuve à certains moments
ça peut que renforcer une amitié est en
fait fernet vraiment une amitié qui pour
moi
bah va être dur et j'ai découvert de
nouvelles travers culinairement parlant
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas les mêmes les
mêmes chaise à la réunion nous il est
que la guadeloupe et la martinique on a
aussi une histoire commune mais il ya
pas mal de différences et pouvoir faire
ce qu'on la grâce est grâce à ce
programme va c'est super intéressant
pour moi surtout en passant par des
activités sportives
[Musique]
des forces d'une souris
aux scarlets
g
[Musique]